STEPHANIE WONG:
What's up, everyone?
Thanks for checking
out This Week
in Cloud, where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Now, there's a lot of
great content at Next,
and I mean a lot,
so much that, well,
sorting through all the
sessions to find the best
ones for you can be stressful.
That's why every day this week,
we're publishing different
playlists of can't-miss
sessions based on subject area.
Today's list-- data
management, AppDev,
and cloud infrastructure.
Check back later this week
for data analytics, security,
and machine learning.
This week on the
GCP blog, learn how
to get the most out of Next.
Start building your
playlist today,
because we're headed to Google
Next '19 in just under a month.
And speaking of Next, if you
haven't earned your cloud
certifications yet, this could
be the perfect opportunity.
Why get certified?
Perhaps the fact that
our certification
for professional cloud
architect was just
named the top paying
IT certification.
Or maybe you just want to show
the world what you can do.
Any way you take it across
the industry, demand
for these roles is exploding,
and so has our list
of available certifications.
We'll be offering these exams
at tons of convenient times
throughout Next, so go sign up.
One of the big topics at
Next is machine learning.
No matter what level of
machine learning you're
looking to get involved with,
Google has what you need.
If you want to try training
a model without any code,
you can use AutoML.
But if you need a more complex
model and want to go deeper,
you probably want
to use TensorFlow,
which is easier to experiment
with, now more than ever,
thanks to our deep
learning VM instances.
These instances are
spun up with TensorFlow
and other tools
pre-installed to get you up
and running right away.
You can even include GPUs
while setting them up,
so see what you can build.
Now, if you've ever been
extra concerned about who
might be reading your
email, have you heard
about Gmail confidential mode?
Confidential mode
automatically removes
the option of forward, copy,
download, or print messages.
It also lets you
set requirements,
so recipients must complete
a text message verification
prior to opening and viewing
an email that you send them.
So that way, you can be sure
only your intended audience
can see what you've sent.
Try out the beta by
clicking Confidential
Mode in Gmail's user settings.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.